Claire were here at the Phoenix cinema
in London for the screening of booked
out tell us about your character in the
film and my character I play Jacqueline
and she's she's grieving and the whole
process throughout the film is her
journey in through the grief yep that's
quite a challenging role isn't it
because it's not a dialogue heavy role
but you've got a lot to communicate so
how did you go about doing that and well
that's actually what drew me to the role
when i first read brian's scripts and
the fact that she didn't have much
dialogue and i found a lot of films are
very dialogue heavy and you missed those
awkward silences and there's interesting
moments and so the fact that she didn't
have much was I was really excited about
and yeah as far as the process goes for
her character was pretty much the same
as any any other character and just a
lot of research and yeah and the same
subprocess have to for any character
with or without dialogue and you also
had some challenges on sent didn't you
because I believe that Brian the writer
director of the Peace wanted you not to
interact with one of the other one of
the other leads in a film nirenberg the
actress who plays a Lee and that also he
wanted you to keep quite quiet on set as
well how did he find both those two
things a difficult yeah and the second
one keeping quiet on set and not
speaking to any crew I found really hard
and especially on the first day I just
wanted to go off and reduce myself and
chat to everybody and I had to pretty
much blank everybody and it felt really
mean but they were prepped before hand
so they knew was it was what I was doing
and yeah I managed to do quite a bit of
it like that but every now and again I
broke during lunch I needed to have a
bit of light relief I couldn't keep it
up all the time but I think what we did
do definitely helped the character and
with ailee trying to ignore her was
really difficult especially like when we
were on really small locations and would
literally be in the same car sometimes
with our backs to each other with
earphones in like blank and each other
but now I think it I think it works well
and I think added to the attention and
when we do first meet in the film and
you had an interesting audition as well
didn't you both in terms of the piece
that you chose and in terms of the
reception of one of the people who was
in the room
the time I think I'll the dog it but all
the way through my edition I finally
didn't bother anybody else's yeah yeah
mm yeah and then the piece I chose and
because brian wants to just do a
monologue I didn't really want to go in
with a theater monologue that was all
big and huge on camera and so I looked
at films and I wanted a monologue that
was close to what i thought at the time
Jacqueline's character was or at least
had the same sort of same sort of say
most of junior needs and wants and and
so I chose him charlize theron and
voiceover in Monster as it's a voiceover
I thought you also didn't have anything
to compare me do it to it and but yeah
it did go it went well so it's a great
monologue fantastic and why should
audiences come out for a film like book
doubt and I think it's just amazing what
Brian's managed to put together it's his
first feature film his first film full
stop it's never even on a short film
before and it's a really nice true on
his story of friendships and real
characters it's a real character driven
film and you're so supportive of
independent cinema which is 0 is great
you